I'm great solving if you don't know now
you know your life is better now yeah hi
guys i'm here at a falcon edition
extraordinaire yeah yeah you've mastered
the refinement of dumb cuisine so dumb
it's mark yeah so here's a little
backstory last year around this time Jay
and I were on book tour and we were so
tired in London in a cab and we were so
hungry that we just heard fantasizing
about the idea of taking tacos and
putting them on the stick like a cake
pop and making like taco pop I tweeted
out about it yeah saw the tweet and
actually made taco pop and I thought why
not have you teach me how to make them
yeah I'm so excited because I love
anything that you can travel with and
eat yeah handheld food is the most fun
food through your hands are your best
utensils okay so how do we do this we're
bringing a little bit of an arts and
crafts element into this DIY DIY
aquaponics
I'm cooking find some scissors scissors
and some flour tortillas but these are
for kids aren't malleable enough for us
to create these pops to wrestle them in
the microwave the tortillas are actually
going to be like the stick of the paçoca
rather than sticking a lollipop stick
into these let's take cheese sticks
which you're so obsessed with I love
string cheese so much and I feel like
more adults should utilize it in their
everyday well why aren't adults using
anymore who said that string cheese for
kids an idiot said that psychopath yeah
anyways we're going to use this as a
stick and then we're going to cover it
in this and then mold it so that it
becomes a cheese filled stick now we're
gonna fill with talk of stuff oh my god
so saying okay the first micro gs1 on
microwave for 15 seconds pen on one side
flip file on the other okay I've already
pre-made some taco meat have you ever
made cheesy taco meat now what do you do
it while the meat is is hot and browning
I had a bunch of shredded cheese to it
and I mix it up and it becomes just like
gooey gooey deliciousness why don't want
people do that as much cheese as you
want I personally put a lot does it end
up getting to be too much cheese is that
even a statement yeah that that looks
good we want more if you just like I
love that yeah I love it it's beautiful
gorgeous and what happens up here at the
tortilla that's cool 15 seconds stop it
at 10 okay flip knees and put it into
the dollars that it alright this is the
fun part and what we're going to do is
we're going to take this cheese stick in
one hand flour tortilla and the other
we're going to put it in the middle of
it or somewhat in the middle it's a very
very exciting where you want to put it
in the middle then flip it over okay
right at four in the center this is
there's no scientific way to do this the
whole trick is that you want to have a
cup on the inside like that and you want
to work a little bit fast these are like
snowflakes every one is a little bit
different a bit different and you know a
cup how do you do that okay that's kind
of like a cup fish and then you want to
squeeze the bottom squeeze because we're
making the stick right oh I see and
that's why we nuke them yeah now the
arts-and-crafts comes to the plate okay
what happens here we retire around the
top like this and these are fun to do
like on a first date or something really
because you have to like help each other
yeah it really shows the camaraderie of
your potential relationship yeah and
they're like a little bit stressful so
it's like showing how you react to
pressure
I literally just tied it one okay I'm up
is look up yeah so just snip the excess
rope because we're putting this in the
oven okay right like there yep and then
you need one tiny one please okay
BAM perfect so we're putting these in
the oven we're putting them in the oven
I bet you're really concerned about how
they're going to stay operating the oven
yeah how do they stay upright in the
oven Josh we're going to implement a
little bit of kitchen youa tea into this
recipe what's that word it's an engineer
in the kitchen okay oh well thank you I
feel like the prettiest bride on their
wedding day this is just the rack of my
oven right what are we creating oven to
350 degrees for three hundred and fifty
degrees pre-heat your oven we're gonna
stick these things inside of this what
and so you can make a lot of these all
at once yeah you could do so many keep
the change
yeah it's gonna melt I'm all like gooey
and delicious and awesome I know we're
going to fill with taco stuff and eat
and that's taco pop I can't wait in the
magic
of internet jump-cut our tortillas have
been the ovens look how beautiful they
look and the cheese inside has melted
but it's like created a nice little base
now all we do is construct our taco cake
pop ish okay thing anyway we want first
thing we need to do is cut off the Roll
I'm thinking that the choking hazard yes
yep all right census question he's the
chef person do they stay together oh
yeah you bake the tortilla it ends up
sticking the cheese inside like glues it
together yeah even if you wanted to just
make let's say like a taco bowl you flip
a muffin tray upside down and just fit a
tortilla in the groove you don't even
need string the grooves will hold it
together and boom okay so take the most
cup like one that's pretty confident yes
it is beautiful it's like a taco ice
cream cones
okay I'm this one hands in because
they're clean ish yeah yeah I trust you
Hennis Yulin BAM clamp clamp oh my god I
was so excited the hot sauce oh my god
you have got a thing for you yeah do it
yeah pretty pretty height there you do
it I want it I want scare you with my
hot sauce poured I know pretty light Oh
hot sauce
I'm sure you go go pretty heavy yep
there you have it what these are our
taco pop ice cream taco cones tackle
pops maybe you guys can suggest a clever
and fun name for this dish because we
haven't totally figured that out and you
believe it took an entire year for this
to actually come to fruition I know but
it really is a guy Ann was saying
earlier the secret we manifest and we
put it out into the universe and you
made it happen okay Cheers care happy
taco popping oh that was the best part
is that we're holding it yeah this will
go like a baseball game it'll go to like
a funeral now watch this what you're
crazy I mean he's in the bottom here oh
my god gosh thank you so much for making
my dreams a reality in the most literal
way possible if you guys haven't already
check out josh's channel please do we
made a video over there where we made
breakfast Tater Tot I know that that
sounds crazy but they were so crazy
delicious race made hollandaise sauce
for the first time ever and not
out in the park weather alert it's
really easy to do go check it out also
and Josh's Instagram is one of the most
beautiful like food curated instagrams
I've ever experienced thank you guys so
much for watching and thank you josh for
just making real magic happens
yeah we made it together we did it I
don't know and where else when they went
across the internet just Josh L oh you
know it's the Josh Elkin as I am the
Josh of his Aviva the Josh Alcon on
everything social media except for
snapchat
that's Mookie Watson got a big old
jacket